[Música]
hola hola hola cómo están allá arriba
también cómo están muchas gracias por
venir me siento muy honrada de poder
estar en esta bellísima región de la
repubblica se come espectacular la gente
es increíble que bonito este lugar y la
verdad es que vamos a hablar de un tema
que es muy interesante y que está de
moda y qué bueno que esta clase de temas
estén de moda pero para que podamos
entender algunos conceptos básicos para
que podamos partir de una misma base
bueno pues me puse un poquito teórica
así que vamos a arrancar con la
presentación si me hacen favor ok la
resiliencia no se habla mucho de que
todos tenemos la capacidad de ser
resilientes y la resiliencia está
íntimamente ligada a la plasticidad a la
adaptabilidad se hace mucho una analogía
con el bambú el bambú se dobla pero no
se rompe y tiene la capacidad de
sobreponerse a distintas situaciones en
el entorno la capacidad de un cuerpo
forzado para recuperar su tamaño y forma
después de la deformación
especialmente por la tensión de
comprensión es decir cuando un material
una persona un grupo de personas una
sociedad están bajo de extensión o
comprensión qué es lo que pasa después
como respondemos ante esa situación y
esa es una manera de conceptualizar la
resiliencia pero se ha estudiado mucho
respecto de este tema y si bien yo no
soy psicóloga ni me dedico a estudiar
propiamente la conducta de las personas
pues los periodistas somos los
historiadores y las historiadoras del
presente la manera en la que nosotros
planteamos y representamos la realidad
quedará plasmada a futuro y muy
probablemente futuras generaciones
quieran estudiar nuestra época con base
en los medios de comunicación es una
manera muy sencilla de plasmar la
historia vamos a ver hacia dónde nos va
a llevar esta situación porque si
estamos hablando de
ser plásticos yo pienso en un pretzel no
que se dobla y se desdobla pero en
realidad cuando pienso en eso me da más
bien así no es como nos doblamos y nos
desdoblamos y terminamos por tener
formas muy extrañas y adaptándonos al
entorno pero eso no necesariamente tiene
que ver con el concepto de sobreponernos
a ciertas situaciones y de ser
resilientes y acaba van a venir algunos
conceptos que ustedes van a decir pero
permítanme elaborar porque para eso
tengo mis preciados 18 minutos aquí
jones 3000 fue una persona que se dedicó
a estudiar las conductas pero
particularmente la posición de las
mujeres en la sociedad a finales del
siglo 18 en los albores del feminismo y
también cuando estaba surgiendo en la
revolución francesa él dijo es un tema
sobre el que no se puede saber nada
definitivo y eso suena un poco como que
era la chimoltrufia no que que dice una
cosa pero luego dice otra o bueno
también pueden ser como cinco frases o
menos a no como una no pero no esto
tiene una razón de ser
repito presten atención a esta frase es
un tema sobre el que no se puede saber
nada definitivo y la respuesta que es
ésta esta frase de john stuart mill
tiene que ver con la siguiente pregunta
o el siguiente concepto que él empezó a
cuestionarse y fue de las primeras
personas en la historia de la humanidad
y se preguntó respecto de esta situación
y esto tiene que ver con la naturaleza
de las mujeres
porque siempre que hablamos de la
humanidad hablamos del hombre pero
cuando hablamos de la mujer
hoy en día hablamos de la mujer como si
existiera un solo modelo de mujer cuando
en realidad son los tres mil millones de
mujeres y afortunadamente usted no es
igual que yo no se lo recomiendo ni
usted ni usted ni usted ni usted todas
somos distintas y todas podemos
responder a un patrón de conducta a un
modelo distinto y qué bueno que existen
tantos modelos distintos pero antes de
john stuart mill nadie se lo había
preguntado y yo las quiero y los quiero
invitar a que reflexionen respecto de
esto porque la afirmaba que las mujeres
hemos sido engañadas engatusadas
empujadas y aplastadas en una serie de
contorsiones como el pretzel femeninas
durante tantos siglos que ahora es
bastante imposible definir sus
habilidades y aspiraciones naturales
cuál es la esencia real de las mujeres
que hubiera sido de nosotras sin este
sistema de opresión tan perfecto y tan
antiguo conocido como el patriarcado qué
hubiera pasado si desde un principio
nuestro destino único no hubiese sido la
maternidad y la labor doméstica cuál
hubiera sido nuestra naturaleza si no
hubiese existido el contrato matrimonial
que en realidad es un contrato que sirve
para determinar quién es el padre de los
hijos y que no vaya de repente a
perderse la propiedad hay quienes me ven
con un poco de escepticismo pero no se
preocupen pueden meterse en los libros
de historia y darse cuenta que la
poligamia terminó y nació el matrimonio
con fines meramente comerciales ya
después lo del amor nos lo inventamos y
ahora que el lío traemos no ya estoy
viendo uno para allá que dice un gustaba
un contrato
lo que dice milk es profundamente
interesante porque nos lleva a pensar
entonces cuál es nuestra esencia dentro
de la sociedad como hubiese sido el
destino sin estas contorsiones sin estas
manipulaciones de poder sin este sistema
al que nos hemos sometido durante
milenios porque es casi tan antiguo como
la humanidad misma
y acá viene carlos de que harold xxi
estudia la conducta humana desde la
ciencia es una psicóloga en stanford una
profesora muy famosa que asegura que
podemos cambiar nuestra mentalidad si
concebimos los retos como una
oportunidad para crecer más que un
obstáculo a superar porque si no la
manera en la que encaramos las
situaciones tiene un negativo o un
positivo es como el que ve el vaso medio
lleno el vaso medio vacío y acá yo ya
voy a sonar este como esos libros de
autoayuda de el cambio está en uno mismo
no existen opresiones sistemáticas pero
es cierto que la manera en la que
encaramos las problemáticas es una parte
fundamental de la resiliencia lo estamos
viendo como un reto
una oportunidad para crecer o lo estamos
viendo simplemente como un obstáculo que
tenemos que superar y ahí es en donde
radica
la oportunidad de empezar a cambiar
nuestra conducta individual y colectiva
pero que influyen algunos factores las
creencias que tiene una persona respecto
de sí misma
las metas sentimientos respecto de sus
vínculos y conexiones sociales y las
capacidades de autorregulación ella
enumera estos cuatro factores que
ustedes van a decir
y eso qué tiene que ver
tiene que ver y ahorita se los voy a
platicar por qué porque esos cuatro
factores que les estaba mencionando hace
instantes están intrínsecamente ligados
con la percepción que tenemos de
nosotras mismas y nuestros vínculos
sociales y nuestros vínculos con las
relaciones de poder entonces qué pasa
que tiene que ver dice el changuito y
ahora se va a poner todavía más
rebuscado pero se va a poner muy
interesante porque al igual que el
pretzel le vamos a volver a encontrar el
inicio y el final
alguien sabe bien a qué corresponde esta
imagen
yo creo que la vieron alguna vez en un
libro de la sep
este es telémaco alguien leyó la odisea
nos hicieron leer la fuerza en la
primaria ánimo igual no se acuerdan y
leyeron el resumen o los que ya usaba en
internet se metieron al rincón del vago'
pero es este el 'mago' y su mamá
penélope penélope decide tejer un telar
durante los días y durante las noches lo
despeje porque porque mientras lo dice o
se fue de viaje en este larguísimo viaje
para pelear en la batalla de troya a
penélope vienen a cortejarla otros
hombres y entonces penélope no es nada
tonta les dice está bien nos vamos a
casar cuando yo termine este telar y
penélope durante el día está tejiendo y
en la noche de este eje y entonces el
telar es eterno y mientras ella está
tejiendo y destejiendo este telar
telémaco su hijo que es un chamaco de 13
años imberbe como todos somos a esa edad
está abajo con unos músicos y los
músicos están tocando canciones muy
tristes
penélope baja y le dice a telémaco ya
los músicos que si pudieran tocar
algunas melodías más alegres porque ella
está extrañando el deseo y se pone
triste y telémaco le responde madre mía
vete adentro de la casa
y ocúpate de tus labores propias del
telar y de la rueca el relato estará al
cuidado de los hombres y sobre todo al
mío mío es pues el gobierno de la casa
tiene 13 años que le pasa a chamaco
imberbe lo interesante de esto es que me
a river' y en su libro 'mujeres en el
poder
menciona este episodio como el primer
episodio registrado del silenciamiento
de una mujer del discurso público o
privado y a raíz de entonces yo no sé si
ustedes lo han notado pero en la
política en el periodismo en el deporte
y en la antigua grecia en la polis por
ejemplo los debates públicos eran de
tentados por hombres y este esta frase
el relato estará al cuidado de los
hombres y sobre todo al mío se refiere a
que la voz pública la voz del discurso
la voz de las historias la voz del blog
de las protagonistas será silenciada y
será históricamente detectada por una
sola parte de la sociedad por eso yo les
decía que esto es casi tan antiguo como
la vida misma pero eso no lo justifica
porque ya no vivimos en las cavernas
verdad oa poco usted sigue cuidando el
fuego en su casa pues no acá tampoco veo
que alguien vaya a cazar un bisonte
entonces así como han evolucionado las
conductas humanas también tenemos que
evolucionar nosotros y otra vez como el
changuito ve mucho siendo y esto te que
tiene que ver
estamos en 2016 yo me dedico a hablar de
deportes y yo quiero que me digan qué
diferencia tiene esto con el discurso de
telémaco a su mamá
ya tiene que ver no a dios bendito
porque si no ya me voy me retiro el
regreso su dinero
ya bueno más las palabras me disculparán
pero pues así se maneja el mundo de
internet y hoy en día pues ya me da risa
no pero al igual que mandar a penélope a
trabajar con el telar y con la rueca
diciendo que sus opiniones son
irrelevantes porque el discurso será
detectado por los hombres es esto el
divo de tepito igualito a telémaco yo
creo que también tiene como 13 años
a donde apunto con este tema
básicamente esto es lo que nos han dicho
históricamente no
rían porque es verdad ser bien porque es
de edad y está bien
pero
llevemos el tema un poco más allá y con
ello quiero volver al asunto de la
resiliencia la resiliencia se descubre
después de los hechos cuando atravesamos
una situación que nos doblega cuando el
bambú se dobla y de repente vuelve y no
se quebró ahí es en donde descubrimos
que el bambú es resiliente ahí es en
donde descubrimos la auténtica
plasticidad no encaramos las situaciones
diciendo ah mira qué resiliente soy no
no la vida sería muy fácil si no es una
experiencia
qué entendemos hasta después
y ahí es en donde yo quiero que me
acompañen a entender esta parte del
discurso público que es muy compleja
el deporte y el deporte espectáculo es
probablemente una de las industrias más
lucrativas del siglo 20 y del siglo 21
junto con el cine e internet
es una parte sustancial de la vida
pública
el que las mujeres pretendan insertarse
en el deporte no es únicamente una
cuestión de capricho es una cuestión que
tiene que ver con la participación de la
vida pública quien de aquí sabe quién es
el chicharito alcen la mano por favor
hasta se saben el color no se ve que el
color del pelo ahorita
pero quién sabe quién es el encargado de
la secretaria de cultura en la cámara de
diputados
eso nos habla del poder del deporte y de
la importancia que tiene la vida pública
y para las mujeres el insertarnos dentro
de ese discurso no únicamente como
periodistas sino también como
protagonistas tiene un doble reto y es
doblemente resiliente porque porque
primero hay que insertarse a la práctica
deportiva y posteriormente hay que
aparecer en las narrativas tradicionales
porque no basta únicamente con ser muy
buena sino necesitamos de el aval de los
telemáticos del presente para poder
figurar en esas narrativas de éxito
entonces teniendo en cuenta el poder
mediático de esto les quiero poner
algunos ejemplos históricos aquí están
las mujeres peleando por entrar a los
estadios en irán en 2019 las mujeres no
pueden entrar a los estadios de fútbol
una chica se disfrazaba de hombre para
entrar la descubrieron la castilla la
sentenciaron seis meses a la cárcel y se
inmoló afuera
tribunal y falleció
catherine sweet ser la primera mujer en
correr el maratón de boston de manera
oficial en 1968 cuando le descubrieron
la que hicieron aventar a fuera de la
carrera
méxico- 71 la única selección mayor que
ha llegado a una final de copa del mundo
perdiendo con dinamarca tres goles a
cero y la mayoría de los mexicanos y las
mexicanas no las conocen
serena williams regresó después de un
embarazo de altísimo riesgo casi se
muere se puso este traje para jugar en
roland garros y de lo que se habló fue
de su traje y no de sus logros
deportivos todas estas historias son de
una resiliencia doble el participar el
insertarse en ese mundo tan complejo y
posteriormente figurar en la narrativa
tradicional ya que voy con esto vuelvo a
hablar de estos cuatro puntos que nos
menciona dwight de la resiliencia las
creencias que tiene una persona respecto
de sí misma sus metas sentimientos
respecto de sus vínculos y conexiones
sociales y capacidades de
autorregulación si lo que vemos en la
televisión y en los medios deportivos no
es un reflejo de esto para las niñas y
para las mujeres yo no sé por dónde
podemos llegar les es un mensaje
poderosísimo el estar y el no estar
y entonces acá hay algunas preguntas que
yo les quiero hacer cuáles son los
discursos que reproduce el periodismo
qué es lo que vemos constantemente las
historias que no existen y por qué no
existen entre paréntesis porque nosotros
decidimos cuáles existen o no bueno no
nosotros no los tele makos del presente
y del futuro deciden qué historias
existen y cuáles no
visibilizamos e invisibilizados a través
de esta lectura
cuáles son capaces de alimentar a una
sociedad que está ávida de resiliencia
porque necesitamos mayor plasticidad
necesitamos plasmar esta clase de
discursos y como lo hacemos con esta
clase de ejemplos que además hablan de
la lucha contra las opresiones una mujer
afrodescendiente de compton en un
deporte históricamente racista
literalmente es el deporte blanco es una
historia mágica como vamos a narrar lo
inenarrable bueno hay que proveer de
nuevas preguntas y a mí me parece que
ustedes como audiencia tienen que
empezar a proveerse también a sí mismas
y a sí mismos de nuevas preguntas porque
este es un contexto muy demandante y de
mucha censura y autocensura porque al
telémaco decirle eso a penélope y el
divo de tepito decirme eso a mí nos
orilla a autocensurarnos
y eso influye en los cuatro factores que
les enseñé anteriormente la confianza en
nosotras mismas nuestros vínculos
sociales la importancia que le damos a
nuestra presencia en el mundo
qué emociones y valores buscamos
reproducir desde el discurso de comunico
del deporte el deporte son puras
emociones
pero qué emociones reproducimos ahí la
resiliencia o el odio o la violencia o
el ellos y el nosotros o el compañerismo
el trabajo en equipo que está que qué
discurso está permeando aquí cuáles son
los cantares del presente
y acá es muy importante algo que quiero
compartirles que es un concepto que he
desarrollado que se denomina la
pornomiseria juanita se levanta todos
los días a las cuatro y media de la
mañana no tiene piernas pero sueña con
ser atleta paralímpica se sube un
autobús que no tiene la capacidad de
recibirla adecuadamente y va con un bote
pidiendo dinero para poder ir a su
competencia porque no en vez de ensalzar
la miseria y romantizar la pobreza
cuestionamos cuáles son las condiciones
de desigualdad para que juanita tenga
que atravesar esa clase de situaciones
qué historias de resiliencia vamos a
contar pero hay que contar las de manera
muy inteligente y hay que consumirlas de
manera todavía más inteligente
ustedes el público ustedes los
consumidores ustedes las protagonistas
tienen una enorme capacidad para
enaltecer este discurso y esta
resiliencia que en este tiempo es tan
necesaria que consumimos que estamos
viendo entonces esto no puede
convertirse en el combustible de las
historias tenemos que pensar en formas
de resolución que no sean el fetiche de
la herida
pasa con la liga femenil en méxico ay
mira como no les paguen está bien pero
porque no hablamos también de lo que
hacen bien tenemos que dejar de
romantizar tanto la miseria y empezar a
pensar en cuáles son las condiciones
estructurales que llevan hacia de estas
situaciones y me permito cerrar entonces
para quienes vieron aventuras en pañales
o rugrats la mamá de angélica que dice
sí angélica va a triunfar en una
estructura de poder dominada por los
hombres tiene que comer respirar beber y
sudar autoestima y en ese caso yo les
diría también resiliencia
a través de nuestros cantares tenemos
que dejar de silenciarnos porque si no
vamos a seguir tejiendo y destejiendo
este telar a perpetuidad muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]